it's being called a historic event
US President Donald Trump has met with
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un in the
demilitarized zone between North and
South Korea
Trump shook hands with Kim before
stepping across the line dividing the
two Koreas Trump is the first sitting US
president to enter North Korea he
described it as a great honor Kim also
said it was a great moment and an
expression of willingness to work
towards a new future shortly afterwards
the two leaders held an impromptu news
conference Trump said today's events
were without precedent moments the fact
that we're meeting and I want to thank
chairman Kim for something else when I
put out the social media notification if
he didn't show up
the press was gonna make me look very
bad so you made us both look good and I
appreciate it but we've developed a
great relationship I really think that
if you go back two and a half years and
you look at what was going on prior to
my becoming president it was a very very
bad situation a very dangerous situation
for South Korea for North Korea for the
world and I think the relationship that
we've developed has has been so much to
so many people and it's just an honor to
be with you and it was an honor that you
asked me to step over that line and I
was proud to step over the line I
thought you might do that I wasn't sure
but I was ready to do it and I want to
thank you it's been great been great xxx
historic they were just saying one of
the folks from the meeting was saying
this could be a very historic moment
that I guess that's what
but I enjoy being with you thank you
very much well for more on the story I'm
joined now by journalist
Bruce Harrison who joins us from the
South Korean capital Seoul so Bruce
needless to say quite a historic moment
Donald Trump the first serving US
president to step foot on North Korean
soil what did you make of this well
first off it's President Donald Trump
nothing ever goes as it's expected to
this was a spontaneous invitation and a
spontaneous invitation for a handshake
that we're just hearing now lasted about
50 minutes long so much more than a
handshake I'm not quite sure what they
discussed we're also hearing now that
President Donald Trump has invited Kim
jong-un to the White House and vice
versa there are reports that Kim jong-un
possibly suggested the president Trump
come to Pyongyang as well so on the
surface this looks fantastic for both
leaders they seem to have this this
growing relationship despite the stalled
progress and nuclear talks and by and
large at least here on the Korean
Peninsula I think people are pondering
is this a pivotal moment in the peace
process and will it lead to serious
change well Bruce say you mentioned this
a good relationship Donald Trump often
talking about it even Kim jong-un
just you know mentioning this but did
you think it was obvious from their
meeting today their interaction that the
two of them do really get along I think
it's hard to say if they're actually
close buddies Donald Trump said that he
and Kim jong-un have something special
maybe beyond just the two of them it's
not understood by the rest of the the
White House administration or perhaps
other world leaders but President Donald
Trump and Kim think they connect on on
some sort of wavelength both being
leaders both being strong leaders I've
heard him say what we saw today
obviously Kim jong-un felt it
his interest to make this trip to the
DMZ what exactly he wants to gain from
it is a big question was this for a
domestic audience was this for his
standing in the world it's unclear but
it was smiles and handshakes the
underlying meanings are a bit more
difficult to to try and unearth well we
did hear the North Korean leader Kim
jong-un speak at his meeting with Donald
Trump we have a clip of some of what he
had to say let's have a listen I believe
just looking at this action this is an
expression of president Trump's
willingness to eliminate all the
unfortunate past and open a new future
all right so some positive words there
Bruce this will obviously be a boost for
King John wound his reputation I want it
internationally definitely I mean he was
already given a significant boost when
he met with President Trump in Singapore
the first time he's continued to meet
with world leaders including Chinese
President Xi Jinping Russian President
Vladimir Putin as well as South Korean
president multiple times it's knows no
question this point that he has secured
his leadership in North Korea and that
he has a firm place in Pyongyang among
an elderly now administration that was
started by his father and grandfather
ultimately though when it comes down to
the the peace talks it's unclear what
the next steps will be like I said
before President Trump suggesting the
Kim jong-un come to the White House that
would be an even bigger step for North
Korea at the same time the critics have
already come out and said look at these
photos what does this say well it says
that North the United States is accepted
North Korea as a de facto nuclear state
well not at the facto as a nuclear State
the leader of the United States holding
hands with Kim jong-un crossing the
border it's accepting all these sayings
at previous year's administrations have
tried to distance and have tried to
prevent frankly and president Trump that
doesn't necessarily seem to embrace it
but seems to think this top-down
diplomatic approach is the right way to
he's wrong it could be very bad for the
US government all right so great PR for
both of them as you point out some
critics saying this is nothing more than
political theater ultimately the goal
for the u.s. for Donald Trump is the
complete denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula how likely is that to despite
all these photo ops
once again uncertainties at this time I
think a lot of people are more
optimistic now because this does appear
to be a step in the right direction
despite what happened in Hanoi President
Trump really hyped up that meeting in
Vietnam and then they sat down at the
table and they were on complete opposite
sides as far as moving the the nuclear
issue along North Korea wanting
sanctions relief the u.s. taking a
hard-line position I think that Kim
thought Trump was softening on and
that's unless you give up your nuclear
weapons upfront there's not going to be
any sanctions easing even though they've
met at the border even though it's a
very symbolic location and even though
it's a historic moment for the u.s.
president to step foot in this enemy
country despite all that we don't know
any of the finer details about what's
going on with the nuclear talks what
possibly could the u.s. do to encourage
North Korea to give up its weapons
what could North Korea do further to
encourage the United States to ease up
on its economy North Korea frankly
thinks it's already done enough on the
nuclear weapons front and now it's the
US has turned to act all right
journalists Bruce Harrison in the South
Korean capital Seoul we thank you for
that